[Aplausos]
[Música]
si tuvierais que invertir vuestro dinero
en un país
estoy seguro de que venezuela sería la
última de nuestras opciones verdad pues
mis queridos amigos de visual política
el gobierno de china no piensa como
vosotros
ah
china invierte 20 mil millones de
dólares en venezuela para compensar los
efectos de la caída del precio del
petróleo y no solo hablamos del gobierno
de china os acordáis de goldman sachs
uno de esos bancos estadounidenses que
simbolizan el capitalismo más salvaje
pues también han visto en venezuela una
oportunidad para hacer más dinero
goldman sachs comprados 1800 millones de
dólares de bonos de deuda venezolanos
habéis oído bien mientras venezuela está
sumergida en una de las mayores
catástrofes económicas de este siglo su
gobierno continúa haciendo negocios con
los mayores inversores del planeta eso
explica que pese a la escasez de
alimentos la crisis humanitaria y la
pobreza extrema nicolás maduro esté
comprando armamento de última generación
para mantener a un ejército al que casi
nadie podría atacar un ejército que
tiene más de 5 mil misiles antiaéreos de
fabricación rusa en octubre de este año
2017 maduro volvió a reunirse con
vladimir putin para negociar una nueva
compra de armas
mientras tanto venezuela sigue siendo el
país latinoamericano que más dinero ha
recibido de china y os preguntaréis qué
sentido tiene en lo que a finanzas se
refiere a china le preocupa muy poco las
ideologías y lo mismo ocurre con los
bancos estadounidenses su único objetivo
es ganar dinero y a simple vista no
parece que la venezuela de maduro sea el
mejor sitio para hacer negocios así que
porque venezuela ha acaparado la
atención de tantísimos inversores cuál
es la letra pequeña hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
una apuesta de riesgo veréis si un día
queréis convertiros en un dictador de un
país oprimir a vuestro pueblo y torturar
a nuestros opositores necesitaréis una
cosa muy importante dinero los
ciudadanos de a pie pueden morirse de
hambre pero esos soldados y policías no
pueden perder ni un dólar de su sueldo
lo peor que le puede pasar a un
gobernante como nicolás maduro es que
sus fuerzas de seguridad se revelen
contra su autoridad
sin embargo en venezuela apenas hay
empresas privadas así que no pueden
cobrar impuestos y las exportaciones de
petróleo dejarán de dar beneficios en el
año 2012 en otras palabras que su única
forma de pagar todo ese aparato represor
es pidiendo préstamos al mercado
internacional pero esperar un momento
porque la cosa no es tan fácil como
parece
venezuela es un país sumido en el caos
económico y eso significa que si les
prestas dinero te arriesgas a que nunca
te lo vayan a devolver en este caso
diríamos que es un bono de alto riesgo y
qué hacen los países cuando los
inversores nos decían de que vayan a
devolver las deudas
efectivamente suben el tipo de interés
para que os hagáis una idea el bono
venezolano puede tener una rentabilidad
por encima del 10 o el 12 por ciento
mientras que el alemán que es mucho más
fiable apenas llega al 0 5%
pero hoy esto qué significa vamos a
imaginar que invertimos mil dólares en
bonos venezolanos a diez años
teóricamente dentro de diez años
venezuela nos devolverá los mil dólares
que le hemos prestado pero mientras
tanto todos los años recibiremos 100
dólares en forma de intereses pero
esperar un momento porque ya sé lo que
estáis pensando esto es un negocio
redondo verdad pues no del todo
como os decíamos antes en venezuela- el
riesgo de impago es muy alto por ejemplo
si a los 2 años de comprar los bonos el
gobierno se declara en bancarrota y no
puede pagar nos habremos perdido el 80%
de nuestra inversión y por eso a pesar
de las altas rentabilidades nicolás
maduró lo tenía muy complicado para
vender esos bonos de deuda y eso explica
esta noticia
[Música]
la compra de bonos de goldman sachs en
venezuela desata protestas pago
alrededor de 865 millones de dólares en
unos bonos que valen 2800 millones vale
pero esto qué significa pues que goldman
sachs compró esos bonos de deuda por la
tercera parte de su valor en otras
palabras que teóricamente el gobierno de
venezuela debería pagar dos mil 800
millones de dólares a goldman sachs pese
a que éstos solamente le han prestado
865 y porque venezuela acepta esta
oferta
primero porque necesitan dinero contante
y sonante lo antes posible segundo
porque tampoco esperan devolverlo así
que ahora os preguntaréis por quienes
prestan el dinero si todo el mundo sabe
quién no lo van a devolver dónde está el
negocio
pues el negocio está en los tipos de
interés es decir si venezuela nos paga
un 10 por ciento de esos dos mil 800
millones de dólares todos los años
significa que en poco más de tres años
goldman sachs habría recuperado esos 800
65 millones que había invertido a partir
de ahí todos son beneficios
es decir que los inversores saben que
venezuela puede hacer un impago en
cualquier momento la pregunta es cuando
si venezuela consiguiera aguantar
durante 4 años más sin declararse en
bancarrota la banca gana si no pierde
[Música]
y lo cierto es que nicolás maduro era el
primer interesado en no declararse en
bancarrota por un lado necesita esos
préstamos para poder mantener su aparato
represor por el otro pedevesa la empresa
de petróleos de venezuela tiene
propiedades por todo el mundo fábricas y
refinerías en países como haití o
república dominicana
si caracas se declarase en suspensión de
pagos--
muchas de estas propiedades podrían
correr el riesgo de llegar a ser
embargadas y por eso durante estos años
venezuela ha priorizado el pago de
intereses de la deuda por encima de todo
lo demás para que os hagáis una idea en
los últimos años maduro ha pasado de
tener unas reservas de divisas de casi
50 mil millones de dólares ahorrados a
tener menos de 10.000 y eso explica por
qué revistas tan prestigiosas como
forbes decían cosas como esta sobre la
deuda venezolana
venezuela puede ser el peor país de
latinoamérica pero sus bonos tienen muy
buena pinta incluso donald trump tuvo
que sacar una ley para evitar que los
bancos y fondos de inversión
estadounidenses invirtieron en venezuela
sin embargo mis queridos amigos de
visual política por muchos esfuerzos que
hiciera maduro la economía venezolana no
da para más
venezuela quiere reestructurar su deuda
extranjera el impago aparece como una
posibilidad tal cual como lo oís parece
que tanto goldman sachs como los demás
inversores que compraron la deuda
venezolana a precio de saldo han perdido
la apuesta sin embargo todavía queda un
acreedor al que nicolás maduro no le
quita el sueño
exactamente hablamos del gobierno de la
república popular de china
el títere de china como os decíamos al
principio venezuela es el país
latinoamericano que más dinero ha
recibido de china pero a diferencia de
los bancos extranjeros el gobierno chino
no compra bonos de deuda en el mercado
en su lugar se reúnen directamente con
nicolás maduró y negoció en un préstamo
especial un préstamo que no se devuelve
con dinero sino con petróleo de esta
forma
beijing se garantiza un suministro
continuo pase lo que pase pero esperad
un momento porque esta fórmula también
tiene sus problemas
como ya sabéis los que lleváis tiempo
suscritos a visual político pedevesa es
una empresa hiper burocratizada con
miles de trabajadores contratados en la
época de chávez por puro favoritismo que
eso significa que cada vez les cuesta
más extraer su petróleo es más en los
últimos años casi todos esos envíos de
zumo de dinosaurio llegan con retraso
sin embargo y pese a todo china mantiene
su lealtad hacia venezuela
[Música]
venezuela compra material antidisturbios
de fabricación china tras más de 70
muertos en protestas callejeras y os
preguntaréis por qué llegan a china con
venezuela ahora que tiene problemas para
suministrar petróleo la respuesta está
en el largo plazo
pensadlo bien beijing ya ha prestado
50.000 millones de dólares a caracas
[Aplausos]
ahora solo necesita paciencia para
recuperarlos y estabilidad que nicolás
maduró necesita unos años más para
devolver sus préstamos no pasa nada xi
jinping puede esperar ahora bien hay una
cosa que si podría arriesgar el cobro de
esa deuda y esa cosa es un cambio de
gobierno qué pasaría si la oposición a
nicolás maduro se hiciera con el poder
seguirían tan interesados en pagar sus
deudas a esos gobiernos que han estado
ayudando al líder autoritario que les
metió en la cárcel les torturó son
demasiados riesgos y riesgo es la
palabra menos favorita del partido
comunista chino eso explica cosas como
esta por eso cuando estamos expresando
esta solidaridad con el pueblo chino con
el pueblo venezolano es que estamos
defendiendo el principio carta de la
nación de unidad china ya ha vendido más
de 350 millones de dólares en armas para
que maduro se mantenga en el poder
gracias a estas gestiones
a clases el mejor aliado en la región
básicamente el gobierno de venezuela se
puede convertir en el títere del partido
comunista chino que china quiere
construir infraestructuras en
latinoamérica para completar su famosa
ruta de la seda los diplomáticos
venezolanos les apoyarán sin hacer el
más mínimo cuestionamiento que china
necesita un país para colocar bases
militares venezuela les puede ceder todo
el territorio que haga falta sin hacer
la más mínima protesta en otras palabras
existe un mejor amigo que alguien que
depende de ti para poder sobrevivir pues
juzgar por vosotros mismos
venezuela espera que ningún país impida
la fantástica iniciativa china de la
ruta de la seda sin embargo todavía
queda una duda teniendo tantísimo poder
en este país
china podría exigir otro tipo de
reformas por ejemplo podría exigirle a
maduro que haga despidos masivos en
pedevesa incluso podrían tomar el
control sobre todas estas explotaciones
de petróleo
que la pregunta es hasta qué punto
venezuela puede convertirse en una
colonia china veis que china se
terminará quedando con el petróleo
venezolano para siempre podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
si queréis entender cómo estalló la
crisis venezolana hacer clic en este
otro vídeo y por supuesto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a este canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones que os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo
[Música]
[Aplausos]